what up space fam goals in here from
anime uproar and i'm here today to
discuss the latest
craziest and one of the best ever
chapters of the attack on titan story we
got crazy reveals in this one including
the appearance of more titan shifters
than we ever expected to see
multiple possible deaths and a
combination of all of our flying titan
theories
so make sure to stay tuned for this one
if you do enjoy seeing these monthly
attack on titan reviews and want to keep
them coming then the best thing you can
do is smash that like button and share
this video with any attack on titan fans
that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future attack on titan videos and while
you wait for the next insane chapter to
drop feel free to check out my growing
attack on titan playlist where we got
videos about titan shifters and all of
their powers all the acronyms and their
powers
the titans rank from weakest to
strongest and much more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all now in this chapter
we again
jump to emir fritz the first person to
attain the power of the titans and the
strongest titan in history we learned
before that she was singled out
when the aldians were wondering what
slave released the pig
and then she was released only so others
could try to hunt her down
here we do get a flashback of her
opening a pig cage
suggesting that she was in fact the one
responsible this chapter is called
battle of heaven and earth and it is
definitely one of the craziest battles
and chapters we've seen
and emir being foregrounded is
interesting too this isn't just aaron's
story but her story as well
and aaron needs her permission to use
her power
so she's clearly on board with all this
destruction
and it seems that the cruelty of humans
towards other beings including animals
like the pigs
and other humans as well that she
witnessed first hand made her want to
end this kind of world
and she with her supernatural power sort
of seems to symbolize divine punishment
of humanity thus playing the role of
heaven
in the battle while levi mikasa and the
other seem to be playing the role of
earth in this battle and it's still
anybody's guess how this will all end up
but for now we got a battle with almost
all of the titans present although as i
stated during the last chapter i think
annie and falco are on their way
too at the battle reiner has taken down
the beast titan but
emir is there watching them they realize
that zeke's not there the titan is just
an empty shell like when the warhammer
titan can summon a titan while hiding
its real body
since aaron's titan right now is so
large there is no real chance of them
finding zeke's body right now
so armin is going to use the colossal
titan's explosion ability he tells
people he'll blow this place up and that
they gotta get away
assuring mika said that aaron is
expecting the attack and won't be killed
it will only reveal where zeke and
aaron's bodies are
gene is totally ready to sacrifice his
life letting armin know that if anything
happens
forget about them and use the full power
explosion anyways we get an image of
erwin
who sacrificed himself like a true hero
and we're told that someone who can't
throw
anything away will never be able to
change anything and that is a good
lesson if you want change
you must be prepared to make sacrifices
but these are definitely
very serious sacrifices that ormond has
to consider right now
for armin he has to throw away his sweet
hopes that they can settle this
peacefully
and that they'll go back to the way
things were before the three amigos
meaning
aaron mikasa and armin but even as he
contemplates this
a titan comes into view behind him this
is something that's very powerful about
attack on titan
just as it is powerful in code kias you
have two close friends who grew up
together
who now have clashing philosophies and
have to fight
amongst themselves even if they still
care about one another you can see in
his face how tortured armin is
and no doubt aaron is tortured as well
with what he's been doing a theme here
seems to be whether or not you can fight
monsters without becoming a monster
yourself
and aaron and seemingly emir have
decided that becoming a monster to
defeat monsters is a necessity
then just as everyone is running from
armin we see that that titan who did
appear in the background has taken armin
into its mouth
and this is very important here it's
tongue wrapped around armin and put the
tip of its tongue
in armin's mouth at first this just
seems gross
and fair enough it is but keep in mind
emir doesn't want armin to transform and
by making him unable to hurt himself
he can't initiate the explosive
transformation so he's safe but can't
transform
seemingly a win for both emir and aaron
at least for now
then titans keep appearing from the
bones to everyone's shock
onyankopon is seen and we're told he's
breathing but he's severely injured
annie's father starts asking if he knows
where annie is but there's no way he's
getting a response right now
nevertheless keep in mind that annie is
being mentioned and being made a point
of focus
then we get the other remorseful parent
reiner's mother
who now only begs that reiner doesn't
die the transformation that has taken
place in these two parents
show how sometimes it can take the end
of the world for people to see what's
truly important in life
but it is my hope that through fiction
like attack on titan we can learn to
realize what's important
learn from their mistakes without
actually having to be
in such a terrible situation here people
are straight up saying
that the attack titan is fighting with
the soldiers from paradise island
again lending credence to what i think
aaron might be trying to do
which is make it clear to everyone that
the island-dwelling aldeans are not
evil and should not be targeted by the
world at large
even if aaron's advance is stopped at
some point soon it should be clear to
everyone that the island-dwelling ldns
who used to be viewed as devils
were actually coming to the assistance
of the rest of humanity
even if it meant them risking their
lives so in theory
they wouldn't be a target anymore back
to the battle and even though these
soldiers watching are helpless they
decide to fire cannons at the enemy
not willing to give up the fight until
the bitter end back on aaron's giant
titan the survey corps
and marlene titans are being attacked by
titan after titan and they all have
unique and cool looks to them they are
not mindless titans but rather as the
quick-minded peak points out they are
the 9 titans of times past
which is very cool for all of us attack
on titan fans titan shifters are always
hype but all of these past time shifters
with their interesting designs like an
alligator looking one and a thing
looking armored titan is really cool
they are surrounded by countless of
these titans with their own unique
powers
and they seem to sprout up endlessly it
seems clear that against the divine like
power of emir who remember
was worshiped as a goddess they have no
chance even levi
says he wouldn't charge to armin right
now even if he was in perfect shape
which he's obviously not in and at this
point
it's clear that this is godlike power as
levi said it seems like aaron can revive
the titan shifters of the past
inexhaustibly with the power of the
founding titan keep in mind
aaron could even affect the titan
shifters fighting against him but he
chose to give them the freedom to choose
their own actions
so this is him going easy on them and it
still looks hopeless
it is piku in her card titan form
decides to go after
aaron saying aaron isn't her friend
everyone is shocked and seemingly
against the idea even levi
peake surrounds the attack tightens nape
with explosives but gets
stabbed by the warhammer titan before
she can set them off the warhammer lifts
her
and although we don't see her die this
may well be the end
for her then porco's jaw titan joins the
party
and as we know it has the sharpest claws
and it makes reiner's armor look
completely useless
titans appear way faster than they can
defeat them and they are running out of
thunder spears too
we see peaks titan and the switch for
the bomb as well
clearly emphasizing it but i find it
hard to believe that aaron could be
killed so easily
even if they did set off the explosions
and we just continue to see
new titan shifters of the past including
variations of the warhammer titan and
beast titan
one with antlers straight up hits into
reiner and how perfect is that for the
christmas season by the way a titan
rudolph i totally think isayama did that
on purpose
in the meantime armin realizes that emir
is trying to suffocate him armin also
realizes that for aaron to keep moving
forward he needs to face the will of
emir and so
it seems that the founder emir is also
wishing for humanity's annihilation or
aaron wouldn't get this far and we
discussed that and why
she might feel that way after everything
she's witnessed
we don't need to just look at her
backstory where she was treated horribly
and witnessed others being treated
horribly we can also assume
that she was conscious of everything
people did after she passed on her titan
powers through the titan shifter she
could witness
more and more horrors like the
persecution of the marlenes and then the
persecution of the aldians and much more
it seems like she wants to put an end to
it all in one fell swoop
and although it seems counterintuitive
that you'd end suffering by making
people suffer
we know at this point that aaron and
amir seem to want to end it all by any
means
necessary armin acknowledges that the
founder amir is invincible and questions
if it's really going to end like this
and then he sees beth told who again is
crying and i think it's pretty clear by
this point
that although emir is calling on these
past titan shifters they are not
actually in control of their titan's
actions
so we know when berto's colossal titan
appears that it's just going to be a
slave to emir's will
however it also seems to me that emir is
respecting aaron's wishes because she
should be able to make the titan
shifters opposing her powerless and
unable to fight back
but she seems to be respecting aaron's
wishes to give them free will and the
ability to choose their fate
so for now at least aaron does seem to
have control over
amir's actions to an extent rather than
amir
just using aaron as her slave but what
is really good about this climactic
battle which really feels like the
climax of attack on titan with all of
these titans here
is that we get to see all these titans
from the past the context is different
but seeing the colossal titan
that started it all in season 1 again
really brings us full circle further
suggesting that we are really wrapping
up
soon here the colossal titan takes a
bite out of the armored titan and wow
all titans are not created equal
it's insane how opie the colossal titan
also called the god of destruction
is compared to some of the other titan
powers yes they all have their strengths
but you gotta admit
that the colossal titan is topped here
reiner's mom
is worried seeing her son's titan get
toyed with and destroyed but it seems
clear that reiner was rescued before
being eaten we then jumped to connie who
was passed out and about to get eaten
before mikasa
saves him and levi is over here spitting
out blood
wow it hurts to see this character this
legend who was arguably the most
hyped up character in the entire series
for a really long time
and right now he's falling apart he's on
death's door
and i can't see him recovering to the
levi he once was
right now mikasa definitely seems to
have surpassed him in fighting ability
because as levi himself would admit he's
far from being in prime condition
we then see reiner who was saved by gene
mikasa is putting in the work definitely
mvp of the titan fighting efforts and
she saves the helpless reiner and gene
from a titan threat
reiner mentions he can transform one
more time but gene says what we're all
thinking
reiner's useless titan always ends up in
bad shape
even though it's the armored titan
reiner does not have a good track record
and the threat below is way too much for
him to handle and although gene and
reiner
don't think that they have a chance at
winning at this point jean still wants
to fight to the bitter end
and says that everyone who joined the
survey corps is crazy since by joining
they knew they were making their lives
miserable connie is then about to be
eaten
by a kind of long neck dinosaur looking
titan
but levi saves him his leg appears to
get caught
and levi is thus further nerfed connie
saves levi in return from falling to his
death but
man this is depressing the star of the
survey corps is pretty much
unfit for battle now and more and more
titans keep dropping down from the bones
and materializing
when people say a situation is hopeless
this is what they mean
mikasa refuses to give up though egging
them on
saying she is strong wings appear behind
her
some pretty great imagery there and of
course the wings turn
out to be the wings of the falco titan
with annie and gabby on it mikasa jean
connie reiner and levi get on but
notably armin is still over there
suffocating with a titan tongue in his
mouth
people are psyched to see annie and
although she says she had no choice but
to come
she also says that she's glad she came
obviously this was expected but that
doesn't make it any less intense
now we got all of the titan shifters
here annie's dad who has been emphasized
a lot recently will finally see his
daughter again
this is crazy and we're told that
there's no future to look forward to
at the end of the chapter which is sort
of depressing but also sort of
foregrounds the importance of the
present moment and making the most of
the time they have
left this was hands down one of my
favorite chapters of attack on titan so
far
we got the reunion we got all the past
titan shifters and we got a miracle the
appearance of the legendary
and much longed for flying titan with
the final anime season now airing
i can't stress how hyped i am to see all
of these
amazing scenes animated and also to see
how this
ends where will aaron's moving forward
leave him will there ever be a point
where he'll stop
feeling the need to move forward or will
he keep going until he's killed this is
some crazy stuff
and the fact that humanity's main threat
and villain right now is our main
protagonist
makes it all the more intense and
interesting but anyways that is it for
this one
as always let me know what you thought
of this chapter and what you expect to
happen next
although it's great that annie and falco
are here they also lost armin
and i really don't see them winning in a
physical battle their only hope is to
reach aaron in some different way
i can honestly say i don't know how this
will end at this point
attack on titan has continuously
surprised me like with the basement
reveal and with aaron's evolution
and because of that i am so excited for
the next chapter to come out
that's one of the biggest strengths of
attack on titan in my opinion compared
to a lot of other anime
you just can't be sure about anything
nonetheless
i am sure that you should warhammer
smash that like button if you enjoyed
this review and want to keep them coming
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
titan videos and while you wait for the
next chapter to drop
check out our colossal and growing
attack on time playlist where you'll
find videos about the acronyms
all time shifters ranked from weakest to
strongest and much
much more link to that is in the
description thanks again for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you